This is funny, I didn't
do it on this trip,
but sometimes when I fly
and I have to fill out custom forms,
when it says occupation,
I write fire fighter.
That's how I feel an entrepreneur is
you're always ready for another fire.
Whether it's two o'clock
in the morning or nine 30,
you have to be ready.
And I don't struggle with that
because I've been
practicing it my whole life,
which is why I fear when people try
to become entrepreneurs because it's cool.
Now I worried about that
because it's very hard
every single day I lose.
And unless you're good at
that, you will not like
entrepreneurship.
[Upbeat Music]
- [A Man] You got your perspective.
[Upbeat music]
- [A Man] happy. Don't
you want to be happy?
[Upbeat Music]
- Brazil, how are you?
- [Crowd] Good.
So I'm gonna do about 40 minutes up here.
Then I'm going to actually,
I asked them if we could do some Q and a.
So we'll do some questions
and then we're going
to do a fireside chat.
So first of all, I'm just
very flattered to be here.
Thank you for having me.
For the people in this room
that don't know who I am.
I was born in the Soviet union,
came to America when I was
a three year old child,
a very tough upbringing. We were very poor
when we first came to America.
I lived in a one studio apartment
with seven of my family members,
my parents, my dad worked all the time
and so it was a very rough upbringing,
not a lot of entitlement,
didn't have a lot of stuff.
My natural state was
to be an entrepreneur.
Even at six seven years old,
I was already shoveling snow,
washing people's cars,
selling juice and lemonade and candy.
It was always to do a hustle.
Somewhere along that time in New Jersey,
sports cards became a
very big thing in America,
baseball cards, American football cards,
and I started collecting them
and by the time I was 1314 years old,
I was making one to $3,000 a
weekend as a 13 year old child,
which you can imagine,
feels like you're a millionaire.
Eventually my dad worked very hard
and saved all his money
and he bought a small
liquor store in New Jersey.
I was forced to work in that store.
And that is really where
I started my real career.
I fell in love with the idea of knowing
that a lot of people in
America collected wine,
and that was what kind of connected me
to my family business.
The part of the story that
gets interesting for this room
is what happens next.
Knowing that there's
a lot of entrepreneurs
in here knowing there's a
lot of small businesses,
a lot of small business agencies,
what really enables me,
the great flattering
nature to be in this room
is the fact that my entire career
was based on how do
I build something with
not a lot of money.
You know, we live in a world
right now where a lot of people
and how many by show of hands,
how many people in this
room are entrepreneurs
and have their own business?
Raise your hands, raise it high.
Thank you.
So if we can keep the lights on,
that'd be amazing.
I love that.
So for me,
what's interesting about
all those hands that are up
is I'm older,
I'm 43 about to be 44 next week
and when I grew up,
the idea of raising capital
was extremely foreign.
One of the most interesting things
being an American businessman
when I travel nationally,
internationally
and other places in the world is everybody
is so caught up with raising
money for their startup.
This has become an entire
generation of hands
in the air that think
about raising capital
and appeasing venture
capitalists and investors,
not actually building a business
and not having the focus there.
And to me this is very interesting
because it's led to a lot
of very different behavior.
For me, everything was always
about how do you make money
and that's what you invest
back into your business,
not how do you raise capital.
When I started my current company,
Vayner media, which is
an advertising agency,
I started it in the conference
room of another company
because I had no money and I
wasn't going to raise money
for the business. I was just
going to find my first client.
Use those dollars and
just keep reinvesting.
It took longer but longer was it strength?
I think one of the most important words
for me to communicate in this
talk today by far is patience.
I promise you,
no matter what you're doing in this room,
and especially as I look around this room,
first of all,
everyone's uncomfortably
attractive and number two
and number two,
but more importantly,
this is quite a young audience
and I think the reality is the thing that
I spend most of my time
on is trying to get people
to understand that patience
is a very important variable
of success
and more importantly
that I believe the far majority of people
in this room do not have a
great relationship with time.
I am fascinated by people in
this room who are stressed
at the ages of 18 and 22 and 25 and 29
like they're running out of time.
How many people by show of
hands are under 30 years old?
So for me,
as you can imagine,
when I see all those hands go up,
you can put your hand down.
Yeah, you're good.
Okay, good.
When I see all those hands go up
and I know in my mind what
the way that modern medicine
and technology is going,
that the farm majority of
this room is going to live
for another 80 years.
It really gets me excited slash concerned
when people want their
business to be huge next year.
The quicker you want it,
the more vulnerable you are,
the quicker you want it,
the more vulnerable you are.
And what has been very fascinating for me
is even though on YouTube
and Instagram and maybe some
of the places you guys see me,
maybe my energy is high, maybe
my style of communication
is fast, but my business
actions are extremely slow
and so what business actions
that lead to slowness lead
to is a couple things.
One, the far majority of
my career I had no money
so I had to always look for places
where you could get a lot more for less.
What I look for in the digital world.
This world is organic reach.
When I think about organic reach
and when I think about organic attention
as my slide says up here,
I day trade attention for me every day
I look at the data both in the analytics
and in the culture conversations
to try to figure out
where should I market.
I promise you one thing,
my friends, no matter what
you do in this audience,
no matter what your ambition is,
the one thing that combines all of us,
whether we're starting tomorrow,
whether we're an employee,
whether we have a huge company
or haven't even started
and are starting next year,
the one requirement for all of us
is to have somebody's attention.
Before you can sell anything,
you need somebody's attention.
Then what you say in the written word,
in audio or in video becomes the variable
if you are successful.
The reason I follow attention
is if there was nobody
in here right now and
I was giving this talk,
I would have no potential
to achieve what I want.
At the same token with
all of you in this room.
What I talk about for the next hour
and a half is the burial of my success.
There are many of you here
that don't know who I am.
You'll leave with an opinion.
There's many people who do know who I am
and you're either going to
like me more or like me,
less completely predicated on
the content that I put out.
I spend my life in a very basic mind frame
and if you look at the
politics of your country,
my country, if you look at the businesses,
it's all one very simple game.
Do you understand where the
people are and they're consuming
and do you understand how
to do the written words,
the audio or the video to
put in those platforms?
This is how it's always been.
Television, radio, print,
outdoor billboards.
It's always been the same game.
Where is the attention,
the eyes and the ears
and what is our capability
to put content in it?
Now here's where it gets different.
This thing is fucking crazy.
This thing is unbelievably underestimated.
We in this room, take this for granted.
The power of a phone in
today's world is remarkable.
The fact that every one
of us are sitting here
with the internet in our hands right now
is actually remarkable.
For somebody like me at 43 years old
when I was 28 I could not leave the office
or my home and have
the internet in my hand
when I was 30 you have to understand
how big of a deal that is.
You have to understand how
quickly this is all happening,
whether it's WhatsApp
or YouTube or Instagram
or tick tock or Twitter.
The fact that these platforms
sit on top of this device
and they're accessible right now.
The fact that there are
tons of people right now
with a phone recording this talk
and then have the ability to post it.
My friends from Brazil to New
York to London to Shanghai,
the human race has not quantified
how substantial this shift
of the internet has become.
And I tell you this and I
start my talk here today
with this cause.
Here's the real honest truth
about how the game of life and
definitely businesses played.
The quickest way to be happy in life,
let alone business is
to be 100% accountable.
The quickest way to be
unhappy is to blame.
If you really understood the
last five to seven minutes
of what I just said,
the fact that how many
people here have a cell phone
raise your hands.
Good.
Every single person here fundamentally
is not allowed to have an excuse
because the power of what's in your hand.
Of course there's family dynamics.
Of course there's tragedies.
Of course there's government involvements.
Of course there's a million reasons,
but the reality is we have
never lived through a time
where people at scale
had so much opportunity.
When I do the homework
on the Brazilian market
and I see the cost for a
YouTube ad or an Instagram ad
and I see how low it is,
when I see how much still
unbelievable untapped potential
on LinkedIn and tick tock
and other platforms are for organic reach
where you have to spend no money, none,
and you can get awareness.
The fact that podcasting is
exploding in this country
and the cost to start a
podcast is to just record it
on your phone and upload it.
The thing that I've become
unbelievably fascinated
by is I know in this
room the single reason
whatever is not happening
for you is your ability
to say no before you've tried.
That to me is unbelievable.
What's unbelievable to me
is it's as simple as this.
If you are capable of writing words,
recording videos on your phone
or recording your thoughts
in audio on your phone,
your business can grow.
Your idea can be flourished.
Your personal brand is an influencer,
your advertising shop,
trying to get more customers,
whatever you want to be. The governor,
you want to be a YouTube celebrity.
The reality is the cost is zero.
The mindset is the tricky part.
90% of this audience does not post
as often as they should on these platforms
because they worry about
the judgment of their family
or strangers.
This is a very, very,
very fascinating dilemma
in our society.
There are people who are not posting.
I mean, look how many people
here follow my content.
Give me a sense.
Raise your hands.
Thank you.
So for the hands that went up,
you know what you're going
to get from me today.
I'm very consistent.
You can,
I'm sure you're in your
head knowing every word
I'm about to say.
As I start a sentence,
I'm incapable of talking about
something I don't believe in.
The nuances are different.
Obviously Twitter doesn't
play in this country
the same way it does in the U S right.
Tic-tacs moving quicker in Asia
and the U S than it is in other places.
LinkedIn's acting a
little bit different here.
What's up has higher growth here
than it does in the U S
there's nuance differences,
but my friends,
this is not about America or Brazil.
This is about human beings.
In America, in Brazil, in China,
people worry about their parents' opinion.
people care about strangers
making fun of them.
In the comments in America,
in Brazil, in China,
the opportunity to build your business
or your personal brand
has never been easier.
Easier.
People see more people doing it
and they think they're too late.
The real answer is 99%
of the people in here
do not have the patients and
stomach to actually achieve it.
They want it so fast. My friends,
I did wine library TV on
YouTube in 2006 excuse me,
2007 to 2010 for 35 minutes
a day, five days a week.
I would stay up and
work on Twitter for four
or five hours looking for
people who were talking
about wine and for three years, every day,
very little happened for me.
Very little people now start
an Instagram account post
for six weeks and give up
because they're not
getting enough followers.
We've become remarkably impatient.
We've become remarkably
entitled and so the reality is,
is the following tactically,
tactically, how many people
here are B2B companies?
They have an agency servicing
clients or some of them major.
You're in a B2B business.
Raise your hands for everybody
that raised your hand.
You must.
You must do one of two things
consistently, starting tomorrow.
Number one, start a
podcast in your industry.
You must start a podcast,
go on LinkedIn,
go into your inbox and email 25 50 people
and ask them to be guests on your show.
And number two, you must
attack LinkedIn more.
I think people very much underestimate
how much is happening
there in this market.
I did the homework, it's there.
It, people don't see it
because not that many people are doing it,
which is the reason it's most interesting.
It's, so funny when I
speak at these events,
people always fall into two groups.
Number one, they don't want
to do it cause it's new
and they want to see other
people do it before they do it.
Or number two, other people are doing it
so they think they're too late
so they didn't want to do it.
People are split up in
two places of not doing.
We live in a world,
a world where everybody has a reason for,
no, I can't do it because of this.
I don't have the money.
I don't have the team.
My industry doesn't want to do it.
I can't.
The fundamental difference
in the game today
is the people that say yes blindly versus
the people that say no blindly.
The only unique leverage
you have in this room
is you yourself.
There's so much information
now you're not coming up
with any new idea.
There's nothing I say that is a new idea.
People have been around too long.
I'm not the first person
to talk about kindness
or gratitude or empathy
or hard work or context.
I'm really not.
I'm just doing it my way in the way,
my perspective,
my words on my platform
and for me is the real
conversation today to me
is today gonna be the conference.
Is today going to be the time
that you finally understand
that it is time to put it out.
It is time to tell your
story at scale contextually
across all platforms,
recognizing that a lot of
people did not raise their hand
and this may be the first time
that a lot of you are seeing me.
I'm just going to take one more step back.
I believe that what the internet is doing
is eliminating the middle.
It's eliminating the middle,
the distribution.
When you look at Uber or Amazon
or if you look at Netflix,
what it's really doing is
separating out the middle
and it's leaping it to one of two places.
The product, the story, the service,
and your ability to tell that story.
I believe this is very important
because this is not even for
the youngsters in this room.
This is not the world we
necessarily grew up with.
A world where the entire
middle of distribution
has been commoditized
because the internet has become the middle
and the focus on not just
the quality of the product,
but more importantly,
the deep focus on the
ability to communicate
has never become greater.
The ability to be a communicator in 2020
has now become
disproportionally more powerful
than even the quality of your product.
And that may be confusing
and it's a very interesting debate,
but the reality is a product
is a subjective product.
One more time.
B2B, who does services raise it high?
I just want to get a sense higher.
All of you that just raised your hands.
You know what?
I know sometimes you
think the product's great
but your client thinks that shit.
Other times you kind of know
that the product is shitty,
but the client thinks it's great.
The work is subjective based on the queen
or the King on the other side
who gets to this side
your ability to be a
phenomenal communicator.
How many people see it where
and how is less subjective?
The content in it is subjective,
but the results are
there through the leads,
through the results that come through it.
I believe today that if
you're in the business world
that the ability to be a communicator,
a content producer at
the height of the scale
for your product has become more important
than any other variable.
I would rather be great at YouTube
and podcasting and LinkedIn and Instagram.
Then be great at balancing my checkbook
that I can hire an for.
This skill is emerging
and accelerating at scale,
so here's how this game
breaks down for me.
One, I think everybody here
has to take a step back
and figure out what
kind of communicator are
they individually.
Even if you sit here today
and do not believe it is your job
within the organization to
communicate up eventually,
especially at the age level
that everybody here is.
Eventually this skill set
will become important to you
whether it's now later in your career,
within your family dynamics
and definitely over the next 2030 40 years
as communication rises in
importance not declines.
Thus my great ask, my great
ambition to fly down here,
three flights to get here
and flying right back home.
The reason for me to be here
is very focused on the notion
of can I get five people?
There's a lot of people here.
Can I get five people in here
to start tomorrow or Monday?
If you want to take the weekend
off to start making content.
The world is very simple.
The world is breaking
into a very simple game,
ideas and making, do you have ideas?
Can you make them?
But it requires an incredible
sense of self awareness.
I'm very passionate for
many people in this room
who are introverted
and who would be scared
to give this speech
or who feel uncomfortable
in front of a camera
to understand that if you
are a remarkable writer,
there an incredible world for you.
For those who are scared to
be in front of the camera
because they're scared of how they look
or they're just uncomfortable.
That recording your ideas
or what you're about in
audio is an incredible time
to be alive and there's an
incredible world to you.
It's a matter of fact,
even more interesting
to me if you're somebody
that likes to doodle
to draw some of the most exciting things
that I'm seeing in my content
is when we're doing cartoons
on LinkedIn and Instagram.
That might be the way that you communicate
when you figure out how you communicate.
Written word, audio, video.
The next part is definitely
the most challenging.
If you ask me why over the last 10 years
I have been given the
great fortune to be here.
It's very simple.
I spend almost all of my time
and all of my content
trying to bring value
with no expectation in return.
If you look at the
content that most people
and companies and organizations put out,
if you look at it carefully
and you dissect it,
it is wildly selfish.
It is either a commercial in itself
or its main objective is to
get you to fill out your email,
your phone number,
your information so that I can sell to you
instead of bring you
value to build a brand.
I wrote a book several years
ago called jab, jab, jab,
right hook,
and the reason I wrote it was
because I was watching
people on social media
really struggle with the
idea of bringing value
and I wanted to give them
a scenario of understanding
that if you're trying to
sell and throw a right hook
all the time, eventually
the other person knows
how to duck everybody.
How many people here
have done email marketing
in their life? Raise your hands.
Great. So for everybody
who just raised your hands,
I was doing email marketing in 1997 1998
and I had 90% open
rates on my email today.
If you're in the 30s you're a hero means
you have a tremendous list
and you're doing a great job.
The reason those lists
have gone from 90 to 30 is
because I'm sure everybody
here knows where I'm going.
We've ruined email because we're spamming
and selling on it at all times.
That's what happens to every platform.
That's exactly what we're
doing on social media.
Now, the reason social
media is subtly declining
and the reason the algorithms
always have to change
is people do not have the
disciplined to not self promote.
People do not have the discipline
to not try to sell on every post.
The other problem is when
people try to make pretend
they're giving value
in disguise underneath,
they're actually trying
to sell my friends.
What's scary about the
way I go about business
and what I believe,
I see what the businesses
that are most winning
in the world is.
It's super basic.
Just nobody wants to do it.
It almost be like if
I was standing up here
talking about health and wellness,
my friends,
if you want to get into better shape,
here's how you do it. Stop eating shit
and workout every day.
Thank you very much.
See you later.
Brazil.
That would be the whole talk.
That is no different than
how I see business today.
Obviously you have to have
a product and service,
but the reality is very simply the formula
is as basic as it is in fitness.
If you are not producing content,
and when I say content,
just to put this into
context for everybody,
next week is my birthday.
I've had my team work for the last month.
We've made a deck,
a couple hundred pages deck.
We're going to give it away for free.
It shows you how to make 60
something pieces of content
in a day.
The reality is the requirement
of how much content
that I'm looking for you
to produce to achieve.
You know about numbers
that look like 30 40 50 60
pieces of content a day.
Most of the businesses and people in here
are putting out one piece of
content a day on a good day,
maybe three a week.
We, if you're a personal brand,
you're killing it and
posting four things a day.
There is nobody that is
achieving the volume.
If you want to write down one word
and stick it in your mirror
from this whole talk,
the word is volume.
This is a volume warfare.
When people hear volume,
they hear quantity.
When they hear quantity,
they don't think that
you could make quality.
They think it's a friction
between quantity and quality.
I believe that the world
has grossly overvalued production quality
and made that quality,
not the story or the
context of the message.
And so as we have spent
the last 30 to 50 years
putting production value
on a pedestal as quality,
we have put ourselves in a
position to not value context
and the actual story
and in that is the rub
and the opportunity,
the sheer size of this country,
the sheer amount of spend,
even in the separation of wealth.
The uncanny amount of attention on YouTube
and Instagram in this
country leads this to be one
of the most interesting
places in the world,
to be a marketer,
to be an influencer,
to be a startup.
However, when I spent,
because I gave a speech in st
pelo a couple of weeks ago,
so about three months ago,
I started really doing homework
on what's the sentiment?
What are people saying in the comments?
What's the vibe?
What's remarkable in such a progressive
and incredible country is how
much similarities there are.
Believe it or not,
what the US which is
with all that in place,
there is still so much cynicism
and pessimism to actually achieve it.
That is not a government
issue with your new president
or ours.
That is not a problem that
you don't have Silicon Valley.
That is a problem that
people would rather complain
than put in the fucking work.
That is a human problem. That
is a global human problem.
If this was 1957 and it was my grandfather
and all of your grandparents,
I would have some empathy
because it real money to
actually do what I'm saying
but in 2019 with this I
struggle to deploy empathy
for you not doing which is
what led me to not making this
a game about your wallet.
Many people think business
is a game of this business
is not a game of this. This is
right now is a game of this.
This has come down to the simple
deep warfare in one's head.
What?
What is stopping people
from actually making content
and I believe that
it comes down to one simple word judgment.
I believe that judgment
is crippling our society.
I am fascinated and grateful.
Grateful like you would not
imagine for my mother building
self esteem in me without
creating entitlement.
My self esteem allows
when I leave here in a couple of hours
and I read the comments
and I control copy it and
translate it from Portuguese
to English where one of you
say that I'm an asshole.
I'm okay.
I want to give the next talk.
I want to make the next piece of content.
My ability to deal with losing pushback.
Negativity.
No. Is my strength, my entire
model of content production.
My entire thesis for this
talk only has one major flaw
in that people are insecure.
I spend my life putting
out content 50 70 80 pieces
a day with the great hope to
eliminate that insecurity,
to challenge you and
ask you what judgment,
why?
Why are you willing to live
a life that ultimately ends
with regret and resentment?
Because everybody who's
90 at a hundred years old
talks about the things they wish they did,
not the things they did.
And so for me, Brazil, very simply,
I'm trying to challenge
this room to understand
the simplicity of the framework
and the massive difficulty in the head
and really lead to a couple tactics.
For example, tactic number
one, one of the biggest things
that I have seen work in
people starting the process
to produce content is
to make a single video
and tell the world their secret
that they've been holding onto.
If you really think about
what stopping people,
it's the darkness and
shadows inside of them
by putting it out and taking
control of your secret,
your dyslexia, your
terrible issue as a child,
your relationship with X,
your drinking problem,
whatever it might be by
you taking control of it,
by putting it out,
no longer does anybody else
have leveraged to expose it.
It is a freedom play and I highly,
and listen, if you really want to know,
forget about the five
people that post tomorrow.
If I can get one person,
one person in here to leave
this conference tonight
and make a video
and tell the world the truth
that they've been holding onto,
this will be mission fucking accomplished.
Thank you dad.
[Crowd Clapping]
I want to go into questions
in about five or 10 minutes,
so let me speak. Let me
see where the mikes are,
but I'm going to line them up here
and we'll figure that out.
But before I do,
I want to spend a few
more minutes on audio.
For a lot of people here,
they missed YouTube,
they missed Instagram.
I believe there's two places
where you have a chance over
the next couple of years
to not miss it.
Number one, you have to watch
ticktock very carefully.
If tick top takes off
seriously in this market,
there will be an enormous
amount of opportunity
because the global penetration in Asia,
the U S Europe is exploding.
What's so amazing to live
in a country of this size
and this much opportunity
and you guys know this,
is you can see these platforms
exploding somewhere else
and you can get a head start
and play it here outside
of orchid, which became the player here.
Every other platform
eventually makes its way here
and became the dominant player.
Please, please do not underestimate
what is happening on ticktock globally
and where the potential
sits in this market.
You should absolutely.
If you're at this conference,
if you're smart enough
to be at this conference,
you should be smart enough to go home
and execute around the thesis
around the opportunities
around the knowledge.
One is tick-tock, number two is voice.
We are becoming much more of
an audio consumption world
by show of hands.
How many people here
now listen to a podcast.
Raise your hands, raise it high.
I want everybody to look around.
Look at this.
Put it down for a second.
Those same people.
How many of you were listening
to a podcast five years ago?
Raise your hand.
Look around.
Look at that growth.
How many people here now when
they watch YouTube videos
sometimes just put the phone down
and listen to it and don't
even watch the video.
Raise your hands.
Look at us.
D rock spends all this time
making it look pretty new.
Fuckers.
Just listened to it.
Audio is becoming the growing
usage because we're busy
and we want to do two things at once.
Three things at once, four things at once.
One of the biggest
opportunities in this room
is understanding how big audio is
and producing audio content.
Everybody wants to be a marketer,
but most people in this
room are salespeople.
It's why they like Google.
Google's easy.
It's intent.
Somebody types something
in, you know they want it.
So you buy the ads and you convert.
That's sales.
I'm here to talk about
branding and marketing.
The way real things are built,
the way the biggest companies
in the world are built.
The biggest personalities,
celebrities, brands,
they're built for branding
and marketing, not sales.
Audio is no question.
The fastest growing
opportunity to build a brand
that most people are not doing.
Please be the person in
this room that goes back
and actually starts a podcast.
Please be the person here
who actually starts recording
their thoughts and just posting the video.
I mean you could
literally take your phone,
hit memo record, put the phone down,
it's just a black screen and
you can post a black screen
with your words.
You can, most of you won't
because you don't think that's quality.
This subjective point
of view around quality
is stopping the world from making.
We must flip that on its head.
Please be the person in
this room that leaves here
and starts making.
Thank you.
[Crowd Clapping]
- I left a lot of time for Q
and a because I really,
the theory is very simple.
The details and the questions matter.
So who's got the mics?
You've got the mics.
- So you've got to run around.
Who's got a question?
Raise your hands.
Yup.
I'm gonna translate to you
- Okay.
- Hi.
- I love you. Actually, my
family, whole family loves you.
- Thank you.
- I just came from Canada.
So I am an immigrant in Canada.
I, Zillow and my son listened
to your podcast every day.
He's nine years old.
- Sorry about him.
- My daughter is 11 years old.
So I ask him, "what do you
want to say to your GaryVee?"
He said, eh, say to him that I love him.
Then he's awesome.
And I'm sorry and you are so fun.
I read it off you.
Thank you for that and bye.
I'm shaking because as an immigrant,
as you know I'm leaving
Canada for 13 years now
and I suffer a lot.
It was terrible.
Even for my children that was born there
and if you're there just
to eat Brazilian food
at the school was very scary.
And my daughter was
bullied because of that.
So my question is,
what can I as a mum do for my kids?
- Sure.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome. Thank you.
- Can I have a photo. Please.
- Yes, you can have a photo.
So I think business
and parenting have a lot of similarities.
So when I hear those kinds of stories,
and I'm sure how many
people here are parents,
raise your hands.
So for all the hands that just went up,
you know how challenging it is?
Like you can have common
sense everywhere else,
but when it's your kids,
it's hard to maintain it.
But I believe that self
esteem is the ultimate cure
to everything.
And I think most parents go
on defense when their kids
are hurting instead of off Bence.
So when their kids are bullied,
they want to go fight the school.
They want to go fight
the parent of the kid.
It's defense for me as
somebody who was bullied
because I was a Soviet
immigrant in America
and my childhood,
when the Soviet union was the enemy,
there was plenty of shit.
I mean, if you can zoom in,
I've got goosebumps.
It was a very challenging time.
but what my mom did was she went insular.
It was authentic.
It was me and her in my own
head hearing nothing else.
By the time I was in high school,
I couldn't hear anybody else.
It didn't matter by the way,
both pro and con. So for me,
I think the thing you can
do is beat into their head
about them, not about the
people in Montreal or Toronto
or Canada.
It's not about them.
It's about yourself inside your own head,
your own self worth and
and you have to pound it.
A lot of parents who are like,
Oh, so easy to say,
but when their kids are making,
you're right,
but it's no different than working out
and eating healthy.
It's no different than may content
and put on all the platforms.
The answer is simple,
pounded into your kid's head,
their own self worth,
not the opinions of others.
There'll be a happy person or whole life.
The problem is most parents
aren't acting that way,
so it's hard for them to give advice
that they don't even feel themselves.
But that is the answer.
You're welcome. Questions.
- Yup.
- Thank you. How are you?
Find you.
- Very good.
- Been following you for many years.
So I am so happy to be
face to face with you.
- Thank you.
- I'm kind of nervous.
- Don't worry.
- Okay. So I came all the way
from extremely little town
in San Quan in Argentina called San Juan.
So, I mean I've been for a couple months
or maybe years praying to figure out
if I have to leave my small town
or I'm just a stay
around there be patients.
I wait for my business to be like big,
- What kind of businesses that are?
- A digital agency
that, so my question is,
would you imagine
yourself as a business man
as a size as you are right now?
Stay in New Jersey for
example, or in a small town.
- I understand.
So the question for you and
everybody here is what's big,
right?
Because, because this is
where people get caught.
It's so simple.
Being in a small town in Argentina
thinking you have to go to San Paolo
or you have to go to Benesede
or you have to go to New York city.
It's easy. It's easy.
You're like, that's a
much bigger place to go.
The question is,
it comes down to what makes you happy.
For me, what makes me
happy is to play the game.
Not the money, not how big or small.
I just want to play.
I've always wanted to play.
I've watched so many people
have a $1 million business
in a small town in
America or in the world,
move to a bigger place,
do 5 million and be very unhappy.
They were very happy at 1
million in their small town.
They went to a bigger town.
They do 10 million and
they're very unhappy.
My friend Brazil. It is time that we,
in the start making
happiness what we go after.
Not more money.
- Thank you.
- We have to, we have to right?
For me when I hear bigger,
I want you to have a bigger fucking smile
on your pretty face. Not make 280,000 more
in fucking net revenue.
You understand?
You have to decide that for yourself.
I don't know.
You, have to decide that for yourself.
[Crowd Clapping]
- Hey Gary,
How are you?
- I'm good. I'm so good.
I'm following you for almost three years
and I just want to see thank
you for all of your content.
You really change it by life
and would mean the world
to have a picture with you. Can I?
- Yes, you can.
Thank you. Right now.
- Right now.
I know. Oh, thank you.
- Give the mic back.
Oh, are you sure?
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
[Crowd clapping]
all right, get out of here.
Let's go. Who's next? Hi,
- Hi, first of all, I'm a huge fan.
- Thank you.
You have taught me a lot about
perspective and gratitude
and happiness.
I'm so nervous.
- Don't be.
- So, me and my sister, we
are starting a B to B company
and we are trying to sell
a training and consulting
for HR teams and litter teams.
- Okay.
And I know we are not putting
as many content as we should.
The other.
- Why? Why do you think? Talk
to me real. We're here. Why?
- Well, she lives in another town,
so it's a little difficult for us to-
- Well, you don't both
have to be in the content.
- Yeah, yeah, no, and, but she
needs a lot of help, for me,
because I know how to
do things and how to,
how to film videos and I'm teaching her.
- Okay.
- And she's a little, she
doesn't have a lot of confidence.
She's really good.
- She knows her craft.
- Yeah.
- So what about writing?
Or what about audio?
I feel like so many people
that don't have confidence
are very scared of the camera,
but can do much, much better
writing or recording audio.
- Yeah.
- This is why I spent so
much time on it in my talk.
I don't want people to
be like me, not listen.
Not everybody is ridiculously
handsome and charismatic,
you know what I mean though?
I don't want people to be like me.
I want people to be like me
where they found their voice
in their medium.
But for a lot of you in
this room that's writing,
if you're more introverted or insecure,
a lot of writers are
come from that framework
or I really like audio,
so keep that in mind,
but keep going.
- And she's doing cold calls
and trying to reach companies
in her region.
But I'm just guessing what else can we do
besides content that I
know who should be doing
- content,
get our first clients just to
- Do it for free.
- Yeah.
- The biggest mistake small companies make
is they don't work for free.
And then, now that I said
this on the internet,
so many people are going to leave comments
and say that I'm an idiot and they hate me
and nobody should work for free
and blah, blah, blah. That's fine.
But those are set by people
that have never started a
company with no customers.
That's right.
And so I mean I did it
and I had already built a big business,
but I went into a new
world where people thought
what I did for the liquor
store was not going to work.
So I worked for free.
I still do it if I think
it's the right strategy.
So I think the biggest thing
you should do is work for free
because it gives you the referral base.
And by the way,
when nobody's hiring you,
that means your work is worth free.
- Can I have a selfie?
- You can, yeah.
- Okay.
- Who's, next on 5 mins?
- Okay
How are you? Go ahead. I can listen.
- Okay. Gary,
[Foreign Language]
- Thank you.
- [Foreign Language]
- Sorry, my fucking life.
- [Foreign language].
- Don't try to convince anybody.
The number one mistake when
you're selling something new
that most people don't understand
is people spend too much
time trying to convince them
instead of finding the person
that already understands
people, make it a noble
mission instead of a business.
My friend,
I've been right and early for
the last 20 years of my life,
I have spent almost no time
trying to convince anybody.
I sometimes have a one hour
meeting with a company,
fly from New York to
Chicago, walk in, sit down.
Start the presentation
and ended after 10 minutes
cause I already know it's over.
Every minute that you spend
trying to convince somebody
who's already know is a minute
that you're not spending.
Trying to find somebody that will say yes,
- [Foreign Language]
- Of course, because you're not,
when you're selling something new,
they can't see it
or they don't have reports in
their company to justify it.
Got it.
So if they don't have the
report to justify your work,
they're scared.
They might agree with you, but
the machine that they work in
won't allow them to say yes.
So you just move on.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
Sign it.
Got it.
Okay.
Next.
- Hey Gary.
- Hello. How are you?
- First of all, you're awesome.
My name is Luca and I watch
our content since on 19
now I'm 22 so thank you
for being part of that.
- Thank you.
- I want you to ask you something
that I believe is really important.
You are the first guy to
talk about making content,
making really quality content.
But I'm afraid that the internet
is a place with very anxiety.
I mean Instagram causes a lot of anxiety
- Instagram doesn't cause anything.
People are anxious.
Yes,
- But this is important.
Instagram, there is no Instagram.
There is a platform.
We post pictures and humans
decide to see somebody having a nice time
and they decide to be upset.
It's important though.
Keep going.
- Yeah. My, question is how can we,
we all here at these event
can help these platforms
are part of platforms being mindful.
Peep better
- By not putting out, by
putting out real shit.
If everybody here didn't
only put out photos
when they're most dressed up,
going to the most fancy place
and showing everybody how
fucking amazing their life is,
the world would be in a better place.
[Crowd Clapping].
- Thank you.
- Not super complicated.
Dirac and I are going to end this talk.
I'm about to do in five minutes.
The fireside chat. We're
going to do a book signing.
We're going to run to the airport.
We're going to take a private plane
cause I have to get to San Palo
cause I want to get home for
family early tomorrow morning.
There will be no picture
of me at a private plane.
I'm not going to show that I'm fancy.
That's not what I want to talk about.
I want to talk about gratitude
and kindness and empathy.
We're in control.
There's no fucking Instagram monster.
There's no YouTube monster.
We're the monster.
[Crowd Clapping].
I don't know who got the mic
Okay.
- Yeah. You'll be when producing
content language matters.
- Yes.
- We are in a country that
doesn't speak English.
- Yes.
- So said that.
How can we break the language
barrier here to go global?
- Well, you're not going to
get Portuguese to go global.
- Yes. I mean what's the better,
best way to go in an English
and Portuguese bilingual.
- Do it both in,
- I mean, but just in one one profile,
but two profiles or
- You can do two profiles.
I'm a big fan of sometimes doing video
that is both in Portuguese
and the English.
I also want to remind you
that this is a humongous fucking country
and winning here is just fine too.
You know?
I mean if you want to win globally
and you're so desperate
to then you're more
than welcome to make English.
- Yeah.
Because current Smathers, I mean Rio,
it's like one and dollars like four.
So it's a big opportunity.
- I understand that.
I think it all comes back to
the gentleman from Argentina.
You have to decide what's right for you.
If you want global,
if you're chasing more dollars
than make English content.
- Okay. So,
- But it's very important.
I say this, I think this is
every country outside of China
and the U S has an inferior complex
because there's more money elsewhere.
This is a huge fucking country.
- Okay.
- And like huge.
- So folks in Brazil,
- If that's what you want to,
but if you know,
I can promise you just focusing in Brazil,
what just Portuguese content
can make you plenty of money
and happiness if you personally
want to be on a bigger stage.
English is something you have to consider.
- Okay. Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- Hey, Gary, good evening?,
- Good evening.
- First of all, you
have to keep you at CBI.
Lulu.
- You have to be
Well you in love you and Russia.
- Yeah. So I'll just give
you a very quick contest
because I want to respect everyone's time.
When I was four years old,
my mom stabbed me for Ethan.
All the cucumbers we had for dad.
- Stubbed you?
- Yes. My hand, yes.
when I was six, she smashed
my face against the wall
until it bled from my nose and teeth.
Just was just because I was late one hour.
Then she threw me at the graveyard
that when it was late at night.
And honestly all my life was
fear and sadness and sorrow.
And so, when I was 20 years old,
I said either I keep myself awake, go.
So I decided, I go and I left my mom
and a few years later I
became an entrepreneur
and I'm not the most successful one,
but I've done pretty good for myself.
Quite happy.
- Good.
- And,
[Crowd clapping]
ah, but
- No, that's a story
that resonates with me.
It's something I share very infrequently,
but my grandmother who
passed away this year,
and maybe that's why I'm a
little bit more comfortable
sharing it.
She was very difficult to my father too
in the Soviet Russia.
So I have a lot of empathy for that story.
And I also know,
and I know you know this,
cause I see you made some
doll with my face on it.
So obviously you're following.
I believe that adversity
in youth is a very powerful
advantage if you're able to get out of it.
If you're lucky enough to
be born with natural mindset
or consume something that
helps you get out of it,
- Well a hundred percent
so I came along the way,
but I did become an
entrepreneur out of vengeance
and wanted to get even with
my mom, my dad, my everyone,
and I knew how unhealthy
it was and then came along
this American Russian
who speaks way too much
and curses even more and
somehow I don't know how,
I really don't know, but,
but you changed me today.
I work for happiness.
I work for hail peanut other people
rather than closing the most deals.
And I came here to
practice what you preach,
which is jab, jab, jab, right hook.
So let's start with the jabs please.
Then we go to the right hook.
- Please.
Thank you.
First of all, Gary Vaynerchuk,
I'd like you to meet Gary Vaynerchuk
Also I'd like you to
meet Sasha Vaynerchuk.
- Very nice
- And to make it devastating.
Tamara Vaynerchuk.
- Very nice.
My two favorite people on earth.
- Yes.
Now I know you're a private man,
so I'll make it in Russia if you want.
I'll do it for free.
I'll do
[Foreign language] 100% Splunk.
Now we just heavily a,
- You send me an email
to Gary at VaynerMedia
and we'll get hooked up.
Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- So
- Thank you.
- Now here's my right code.
And regardless of what [Crowd clapping]
say yes or no, what I said earlier,
I'll a believer,
I desperately need 20
minutes FaceTime with you
whenever you want,
wherever you want, please.
- Okay.
Two things.
One, jab, jab, jab, right hook.
When you give, give, give, and then ask.
It's unbelievably important
to me that people understand
that when you give with
something behind it,
it's not giving.
So the execution of
that for the 20 minutes
is not how I see the world.
However, I just want
to make sure everybody
understands that.
However, even with that said,
and usually it's not my favorite move.
When somebody gives me
something I didn't ask for
and then need something from me,
which is the most valuable thing from me,
my actual time, even
though I don't love that.
I just love you.
- Thank you. I love,
- I will give you the 20 minutes.
- Thank you.
- Your welcome
- Email me, we'll get connected.
- I will
- I'm going to get one more in
and then I'm going to call up the CEO
and we're going to have this far check.
- Last one please.
- You got it.
- I love you.
- I love you back.
- Okay. Thank you.
We own a canabiss growing
side flora 70 years.
We are
rather than contact, jab,
jab, jab, jab, all the time
and the, now the market is
opening for the big companies
coming from United States.
As you know, we can't have
sponsored ads on Facebook.
I'm aware
or Instagram.
- So I'm asking you any advice,
- Influencers, because that's
the most scalable thing.
So giving the dollars to the influencer,
they post and sometimes it stays up,
sometimes it doesn't.
But my number one thing,
I do a lot in the US with cannabis,
with my Greenstreet company.
You have to start a podcast.
You have to control the media podcast
and even text messaging,
starting to ask people for
their cell phone numbers
and putting out content directly to them.
- And we work very hard and chat bot also
- 100% but even the chat bot,
if it's in within the,
if it's in WhatsApp,
you're going to be vulnerable.
You want to go direct phone numbers
and you want to start a podcast company
because there's no platform
in the middle that's in control of you.
- Great.
Thank you.
- Your Welcome. All right,
let's do the fireside chat.
Thank you everyone.
- Gary, this is very good shit.
So do a couple more.
It's all about them so I
can grab my intervention.
Be right here.
- Who's got the mics?
No problem.
I just don't know where the mikes are.
Who's got the mics?
Go ahead.
Yep, she's got it.
Yup, that's fine.
And then let's,
and then let's go into
the way fucking back.
I want to get some of those, those peeps.
- [Tiago] Hello Gary. My name is Tiago,
me and my girlfriend.
We drove 380 miles just
to see you and meet you.
- Thank you.
- I just want to thank you
for everything you did.
I brought pro-Russian with me.
- Thank you.
- This book changed my life.
I'm, I work as a doctor,
but I happened to be
passionate about technology.
So I started my YouTube
channel following our advice
my last year,
one half year ago,
and it started to grow exponentially.
You told me about voice I
made Alexa contacted, blew up.
My girlfriend was unhappy at her job
and I said, read this book.
And then Steve captain
complaining about her job
and I said, quit.
You're not, Gary says quit.
And she quit her job
and now she started her
own slow fashion business.
She's happy as she ever been
and we want to thank you so much
and ask if you could sign my book
and take a picture with us please.
- 100%.
- Thank you.
- 100%
bye.
- Who's got the mic right over there?
Go ahead.
Get her attention.
She's got the mic. Go ahead.
- Yeah, I came from there
because no one is looking
for the people on the sides
and not just, eh, I
think is really important
to talk about a business that
is really neat in Brazil.
That is, it's schools teaching of course,
and I am the first people,
but the first person here
that actually didn't know you
before are this summit.
- No problem. I wasn't, people didn't,
- Yeah, I wasn't a big fan of you.
I am now.
You're a really smart person.
I just wanted your
opinion on how you think
that teaching is going to
grow in these platforms
like YouTube, internet in general.
Do you think that actually
we're going to have a boom,
let's say, teaching is going
to explode on the internet.
Do you think that's a
market in the future?
- I do and I think it's already happened.
I think you and I have grown
up in the last hundred years
of modern teaching where education
is being done through
schools and leveling up
until final university and
then go into the world.
I believe that education
is already happening.
If you just think about what that doctor,
was just saying, literally the question
before he watched my content
in education form it,
educated him to the possibilities
and then he went and executed it.
I think to your point, and you can,
you can add, we can talk back and forth.
I think people that are
educators in the current system
are going to have to be very thoughtful
that are they passionate
about being a teacher
in the current system or they passionate
about educating in the macro?
- Yeah, that's actually the
point I was trying to get,
yeah, I know there's a lot of people,
already teaching other
people on the internet.
My, the thing I was thinking is that,
my idea of future though,
the thing I want to do in my future
is teaching people online
specific languages.
- You could do that now.
- But yeah, I know. But do you,
my question is, do you think,
teaching is gonna go
entirely to the internet,
do you think?
- I think society is
going to go predominantly
to the internet,
will still live in real life,
but there's a very significant
chance in 30 40 50 years
that all of us are
living in virtual reality
and are spending a lot
of time in that world.
No different than the 11 hours we spend
inside our VAR phone now.
Yes, I do.
- Like ready player one. The movie
- Yeah I listened to,
I think people in this room,
including me, are very
naive of where technology
is going already.
We can see blockchain, VR, AR,
there's so many more inventions
that will be invented
before we die.
Technology always moves.
So yes, I think so.
- Thank you.
- Okay. Who's got the next question?
I need the mic
Wait, we got you.
- Okay. [Foreign language] Gary,
- How are you?
- [Foreign language]
- You're going to die.
Yeah, I mean, brother,
My biggest hope for everybody
is to not have regret
besides health,
health, which you need.
I want people to have happiness
and as much happiness
and as little regret.
And you know you're such a young man.
We have so much time.
I just wished that people
had a better relationship
with time.
There's so much more time
and so I'm glad that that hit
you because it's very real.
Everything I do, everything
is knowing that it's almost
impossible to be a human being.
400 trillion to one.
That is the math.
The odds of being a, the
odds of being somebody
in here right now is 400 trillion to one.
It's impossible to be a human being
and yet everybody here is one
and I don't want you to waste it.
Why?
- [Foreign language]
- Thank you. Thank you.
God lets us go. Yep.
- We can do the last one.
Yeah.
- Hi. All right.
Earlier you gave us advice
for producing content
and I as them to they for
Hobart to Prado for Microsoft.
What re twirls do you have
every day that changes your life
and I want what?
- What brother? What?
What rituals re re is yes,
- that do do every day.
And it changes your life
- Every day.
Yeah, every day.
At some point,
I imagine my children or my parents
or my siblings, somebody in
my family dying every day.
And that makes me happy.
And I know that that might be confusing,
but every day I practice reminding myself
what is actually important to me.
And if today I went to Brazil
and gave a great speech
and many people found out about me,
and when I got back to
my phone in an hour,
one of my clients gave us $5
million more for Vayner media.
And one of my videos
went viral on Instagram
and got 5 million views
and maybe even this Sunday,
the jets win a fucking football game.
Right? If all that happened,
if all that happened,
if God forbid one of the 20
people that I love the most
got sick or died, I would not give a shit.
My only ritual every day
is to make pretend somebody
that I loved died,
which makes the rest of my day very easy.
- Amazing. Thank you.
- You're welcome.
[Crowd clapping]
- Do them in a very tough spot here.
I'm cutting this great conversation short.
Yeah. I'm also between you and your flight
and between them and party with free beer.
So,
- Free beer is fun.
- So unfortunately you guys,
this conference is coming to an end.
Did you like it?
[Crowd cheering]
so my only mission here is try
to wrap up this conversation
with some of the important
things that we discussed here.
I think we all agreed that
we had an amazing three days
the last three days.
Those are my questions to you.
I'm a big fan since the wine library days.
I actually met you,
I'd probably don't remember that.
Mad at you at web 2.0 expo 2009.
So that was a long time ago.
- In Portugal?
- Yeah, in San Francisco.
So my first question is
you want to buy the jets?
- Yes.
- Most people here
probably don't know why.
So what I want to know is,
what's the power of stating
out publicly a goal like that?
And please explain why
you went about it yet.
- When I was five years
old, six years old,
I moved to New Jersey.
I wasn't speaking English.
I had a very tough time in.
When I first came to America.
I went outside and some boys were throwing
in American football.
I went over, started playing,
and they said to me,
what team do you like?
I didn't know.
They said, you're in New York jets fan.
I, okay. That was 1982
every single Sunday.
Since that day I have watched
every single play of the jets.
During that summer or a year later,
all my friends had jets, jerseys.
We were poor.
So asked my mom to buy a
jet shirt and she said no,
but at night she knitted
and made me a jet sweater.
That is my prize possession.
I have it in a safety deposit box.
When I buy the football team,
I'm going to hang it
as soon as you walk in.
For me the jets means
America means happiness
means the beginning of my life.
When I started,
when I was in fifth grade,
they asked us, who do you
want to be when you grow up?
And everybody wrote police,
man, astronaut,
all sorts of different stuff
and I wrote the owner of the New York jets
and that was the first
time I said it publicly
and I've said it basically
to everybody I've met since
and then obviously over the
last 10 years as more people
got to know me, it's a part of my story.
It's very important.
It's actually very similar
to the nice gentleman
from Argentina.
It you have to be self aware.
For me, entrepreneurship
and building businesses has
always been my happiness.
Lemonade when I was five to
being right here with you today
at 43 so for me wanting
to buy the New York jets
is very important
because it's a goal that allows me to play
for a very long time and that
is what brings me happiness,
the process.
As a matter of fact,
I've already made a video
maybe five or six years ago
that I have saved
and it's the video that I'm
going to share with the world.
The day I buy the New York jets
and in the video I tell everybody
that today is a sad day.
Not a happy day
because something that I've been chasing
for a very long time has
come to a conclusion.
And then I make a joke
about winning a Superbowl
and something like that. But nonetheless,
it's important for me not
because you shoot for the moon
and you land in the mountains.
It's important to me because
it represents a process.
I want everybody here to love
what they do in the process,
not necessarily the stuff
that comes along, money, fame,
vacations, clothes.
I want them to love the
game, not the stuff.
For me, having a big
goal lets me play longer.
- Got it. Got it. Thank you.
- Thank you.
- Last couple of questions.
So, another thing that we
talked a lot about year,
Is this tragal especially
for entrepreneurs.
Now we have to deal with that.
You always talk about hustling,
what keeps you up at night today?
Like, cause you're a successful guy still,
but you still have some, right?
- Yeah. But, but that's
what I signed up for.
Like I don't understand. When
people are trying to aspire
to be unbelievably happy
and unbelievably wealthy,
it should be hard. Like every day is hard.
I landed here from these
three flights to get here
and immediately I get wifi
and there's four texts from clients.
Problem, problem, problem, problem.
It should be hard.
My struggles today are
100% outside the framework
of my business.
For me, that's my safe place
and I accept that there's
going to be tough things.
As a matter of fact, this is funny,
I didn't do it on this trip,
but sometimes when I fly
and I have to fill out custom forms,
when it says occupation,
I write for fire fighter.
That's how I feel an entrepreneur
is you're always ready for another fire,
whether it's two o'clock in the morning
or nine 30 you have to be ready,
and I don't struggle with that
because I've been
practicing it my whole life,
which is why I fear when people
try to become entrepreneurs
because it's cool.
Now I worried about that
because it's very hard
and if you're not used to losing,
I lose every day. Every single day I lose.
And unless you're good at that,
you will not like entrepreneurship.
- And how do you know what's interesting?
- There's something interesting there.
You know where my mind
just when I apologize.
Well my mind just went is,
it's funny where I just
went as we've just finished
that you were about to clap.
I said, I said to myself,
I said, it's hard to lose
when you already lost.
I'm already pop committed to the game.
I know what I signed up for.
You can't lose when you
already think you're losing.
Everybody thinks entrepreneurship.
I'm going to start the next fucking Uber
and be a billionaire. No you're not.
And the second you understand
that is when it gets good.
- And now we run multiple companies.
Most of them are very successful.
How to prioritize her life,
how to balance stuff
and only don't allow
them the word balance,
but juggling.
- And being okay.
The reason most people aren't doing
what I do is I'm okay juggling
and letting something
fall because I don't.
If I was juggling right now, eggs
and you were all impressed
and I dropped an egg
and you all said I wouldn't care.
It's part of the game.
So for me it's easy to do
the wine and the business
and the sneakers and
all the stuff I'm doing
because if something fails,
people will tweet about it.
People will write about
it, but I won't hear it.
What's so important and the one
thing I wish for all of you,
and it was earlier to
the parenting question,
as you can imagine,
especially if you don't know me
and you just discovered me
and you see how people
are talking about me,
you could imagine how
easy it is to get high
when people say that
you're changing their life
and all this unbelievable,
but it's very funny for me.
I don't, when I hear the beautiful things
that are said to me,
I think about Sasha.
I think about my parents.
I think man, they did a good job.
I'm the product of them.
I'm the product of
immigrants and struggling
and good parents. So
when I hear nice things,
I don't get high. But
that's a very good thing
because when people say
the reverse in my comments
or negative things, I don't get low.
When you become detached,
detached from either positive
or negative comments, you win.
The reason so many of you struggle is you
like the compliments.
When people say you're pretty,
you like the compliments.
When people say you're smart,
When you're dressed good,
he came up with a good idea.
You scored a goal.
You made a couple of you like that.
So when, but now you get
used to the feedback.
So then when somebody says your shit,
you believe that too.
I don't believe either.
I hear nothing.
It's super quiet appear.
It's super fucking quiet up here.